what I want to do in this video is
review much of what we've already talked
about and then hopefully build some of
the intuition on why we divide by n
minus 1 if we want to have an unbiased
estimate of the population variance when
we take when we're calculating the
sample variance so let's think about a
population so let's say this is the
population right over here and it is of
size capital n and we also have a sample
of that population so a sample of that
population and it its size we have
lowercase n data points so let's think
about all of the parameters and
statistics that we know about so far so
the first is the idea of the mean of the
mean so if we're trying to calculate the
mean for the population is that going to
be a parameter or a statistic well when
we're trying to calculate it on the
population we are calculating a
parameter we are calculating a parameter
so let me write this down so this is
going to be so for the population
population we are calculating a
parameter it is a parameter and when we
calculate when we attempt to calculate
something for a sample a sample we would
call that a statistic statistic so how
do we think about the mean for
population well first of all we denote
it with the Greek letter mu and we
essentially take every data point in our
population so we take the sum of every
data point so we start at the first data
point and we go all the way to the
capital n theta point so every data
point we add up so this is the ith data
point so X sub one plus X sub 2 all the
way to X sub Capital n and then we
divide by the total number of data
points we have
well how do we calculate the sample mean
well the sample mean we do a very
similar thing with the sample and we
denote it with a X with a bar over it
and that's going to be taking every
every data point in the sample so going
up to lowercase n adding them up
so these are
all the sum of all the data points in
our sample and then dividing by the
number of data points that we actually
had now the other the other I guess
thing that we're trying to calculate for
the population which was a parameter
then we'll also try to calculate it for
the sample and estimated for the
population was the variance which was a
measure of how dispersed or how how much
the data points vary from the mean so
let's write a variance variance right
over here and how do we how do we denote
and calculate variance for a population
well for population we'd say that the
variance we use the Greek letter Sigma
squared is equal to and you could view
it as the mean of the squared distances
from the population mean but what we do
is we take width for each data point so
I equal 1 all the way to N we take that
data point subtract from it the
population mean so if you want to
calculate this you'd want to figure this
out or that's one way to do it we'll see
there's other ways to do it where you
can kind of calculate them at the same
time but you would the easiest or the
most intuitive calculate this first and
for each of the data points take the
data point and subtract it from that
subtract the mean from that square it
and then divide by the total number of
data points you have now we get to the
interesting part sample variance there's
several ways where when people talk
about sample variance there's several I
guess tools and their toolkits or there
are several ways to calculate it one way
is the biased sample variance the the
non unbiased estimator of the population
variance and that's denoted usually
denoted by s with a subscript N and what
is the unbiased estimator you how would
we calculate it well we would calculate
it very similar to how we calculated the
variance right over here but we would do
it for our plot for our sample not our
population so for every data point in
our in our sample so we have n of them
we take that data point and from it we
subtract our sample mean we subtract our
sample mean square it and then divide by
the number of
data points that we have but we already
talked about in the last video how would
we find what is our best unbiased
estimate of the population variance this
is usually what we're trying to get at
we're trying to find an unbiased
estimate of the population variance well
in the last video we talked about that
if we want to have an unbiased estimate
and here in this video I want to give
you a sense of the intuition why we
would take the sum so we're going to go
through every data point in our sample
we're going to take that data point
subtract from it the sample mean square
that but instead of dividing by n we
divide by n minus 1 we're dividing by
we're dividing by a smaller number we're
dividing by a smaller number and when
you divide by a smaller number you're
going to get a larger you're going to
get a larger value so this is going to
be larger this is going to be larger
this is going to be smaller and this one
we refer to the unbiased estimate
unbiased estimate and this one we refer
to the biased estimate biased estimate
if people just right if people just try
to this they're talking about the sample
variance it's a good idea to clarify
which one they're talking about but if
you had to guess and people give you no
no further information they're probably
talking about the unbiased estimate of
the variance so you would probably
divide by n minus 1 but let's think
about let's think about why this
estimate will be would be would be
biased and why we might want to have an
estimate like this this is a lot that is
larger and then maybe in the future we
could have a computer program or
something that really makes us feel
better that dividing by n minus 1 gives
us a better estimate of the true
population variance so let's amay let's
imagine all of the data in a population
and I'm just going to plot them on a
number line all the data so this is my
number line this is my number line and
let me plot all of the data points in my
population so this is some data this is
some data here's some data and here is
some data here and I can just do as many
points as I want so these are just
points on the number line now let's say
I take a sample of this so this is my
entire population
so let's see I'm a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 so in this case what would
be my big end my big end would be 14 big
n would be 14 now let's say I take a
sample a lowercase n of let's say my
sample size is 3 I could take I could
take well before I even think about that
let's think about roughly where the mean
of the this population would sit so the
way I drew it and I'm not going to
calculate it exactly
it looks like the mean might sit
someplace roughly right over here so the
mean the true population mean the
parameter is going to sit right over
here now let's think about what happens
when we sample and I'm going to do just
a very small sample size just to give us
the intuition but this is true of any
sample size so let's say we have sample
size of 3 so there is some possibility
when we take our sample size of 3 that
we happen to sample it in a way that our
sample mean is pretty close to our
population mean so for example if we
sample to that point that point and at
that point I can imagine our sample mean
might actually sit pretty close pretty
close to our population mean but there's
there's there's a distinct possibility
there's a distinct possibility that I
may be when I take a sample I sample
that that and that and the key idea here
is when you take a sample your sample
mean is always going to sit within your
sample and so there's a there is a
possibility that when you take your
sample your mean could even be outside
of the sample and so in this situation
and this is just to give you an
intuition so here your sample mean is
going to be sitting your sample mean is
going to be sitting someplace in there
and so if you were to just calculate the
distance from each of this points to the
sample mean so this distance that
distance and you square it and you were
to divide by the number of data points
you have this is going to be a much
lower estimate than the true variance
the true variance from the actual
population mean where these things are
much much much further now you're always
not going to have the true population
mean outside of your sample but it's
possible that you do so in in general
well this when you just take your points
find the squared distance to your sample
mean which is always going to sit inside
of your data even though the true
population mean could be outside of it
then your or it could be in you know one
end of your data however you might want
to think about it you are likely to be
under estimating you are likely to be
under estimating the true population
variance so this right over here is an
underestimate underestimate and it does
turn out that if you just instead of
dividing by n you divide by n minus 1
you'll get a slightly larger sample
variance and this is a this is an
unbiased estimate in the next video and
I might not to get to it immediately
I would like to generate some type of a
computer program that is more convincing
that this is a better estimate this this
is a better estimate of the population
variance than this is